this theater you know that you've
performed here many times
um this theater the largo theater has
all these pictures backstage
there must be 15 pictures back there of
you
and there's at least 15 pictures of gary
shandling who played here
all the time and i know that you and
gary were super close
do you think about him a lot even even
today oh
yeah all the time boy i miss him so many
times
don't you you were close to them too
yeah sometimes i would call him or need
him or
you know he was first of all in
just seeing you and talking about gary
makes me think about
either you or him were hosting the
yummies i think you were also
i was hosting him and i got gary to do a
bit where we rode together
on a horse on a horse and we had such a
good time
doing that i was sobbing laughing at
that bit
yeah yeah he was it was a bit that
called for me to be riding a horse and
him to be behind me holding me it was a
romantic
on a beach in malibu and uh
yeah i've i saw that clip again
i don't know maybe about a year ago and
tear it up because he's looked so happy
in that moment because it was so silly
it was such a silly bit to do
but he was lovely i ran through all my
material i used to run material past him
and as you know he was a great teacher
and he was
so unselfish about listening material
and he would listen to my jokes and go
that's good okay that's good that's good
wait a minute that one
i don't quite get and i go like it's
gone if he didn't like it i would just
take it out immediately
he was honest but he was so supportive
he was a mentor to so many people you
know we a bunch of us played basketball
and they were like
there are mcis scripts he's helped
people with you know what i mean like
he was so those were the really neurotic
crimes i remember
when uh yeah when uh mark harmon asks if
his
hair looks okay
but um yeah and and it's funny because
every he was so generous like everything
he learned the hard way
he gave to us on a silver platter
and i remember at his memorial a friend
was like
who's gonna be our gary now and i was
like
we have to be the gary's now you know oh
when they asked me i said steven seagal
oh god
i think your answer's better your answer
is more zen i specifically thought we
need a new gary
and quickly said stephen cigar yeah you
can see that now in your comedy
[Laughter]
there's a lot of like low ponytail yeah
and
just a lot of side kicking